bonjour madame bonjour essayé je
voudrais un sceau d'un orange s'il vous
plaît avec plaisir
quel beau temps dans votre ville
voilà merci
il est bon merci vous êtes de passage
si on veut je suis photographe de presse
c'est à dire pour un journal très bien
ce doit être un métier passionnant c'est
vrai mais c'est fatigant et même
quelquefois dangereux tenez par exemple
je viens de parcourir mois plusieurs
milliers de kilomètres pour venir
photographier ici un monstre horrible
un dernier spécimen connu d'un de la
préhistoire et savez vous quelle allure
il a selon elle ce que paris ils
mesurent bien de mettre de l'eau il ya
une arête images sur ses deux pattes de
derrière toi être féroce
vous croyez et quand et sa peau et bien
on dit que sa peau est orange avec des
taches rouges et jaunes dessus doit être
d'une laideur effrayant connaissez vous
son nom les monstres n'ont pas dit non
pas du tout le monstre que vous cherchez
s'appelle kazim kazim où les gens
pouvaient pas du tout le voilà justement
qui arrivent mais voilà
qu'est ce qu'il y a moscou moscou
casimir ouais
monsieur est un photographe de presse
qui est venu pour te prendre en photo
pour son journal un photographe pour des
photos chic alors monsieur qu'elle pose
bulli peu comme ça ou alors comme ceux
ci comme ceci peut-être mais bien sûr il
chante même quasi est une chanson ah oui
pourquoi pas bonne idée
[Musique]
avec une tache en son imagination
j'attends maintenant pour tree hill
aussi du bonheur tranquille
ne soyez pas terrorisé je suis le monde
ribéry
kazim
la boule orange
[Musique]
si l'on manie maladroit
et moi
je sais jouer de la musique
[Musique]
je suis né l'est se maquille amis si
j'aime la glace aussant choix c'est mon
choix et mon droit avec nos chansons
un peu d'imagination
je vous emmène dans notre it is aux
filles du bonheur tranquille
[Musique]
c'est les couleurs rencontrer
ne soyez pas terrorisé
je suis le bon on y fait rire
[Musique]
une malle magique elle une idée je mange
chaud
mihoubi bourgade mais je pense que ça
m'a gêné j'ai vu un leader en khâgne au
cinéma
c'est mon droit cet endroit a vécu deux
chansons
[Musique]
à
imagina
[Musique]
priscilla
hier
ampli
il faut faire
2 soyez
et aussi
je suis le bon sens qui fait rire
[Musique]
casimir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]